This circle will have a radius of 2 and a center at the point negative 3, 1.
Great work if you found those two. Now if you struggled with this, I recommend
going back to looking at completing the square. You'll need this as a helpful
tool for the many of the types of problems, you'll encounter later. We want to
start by subtracting 6 from both sides of the equation. So we'll have negative
6 on the right, and then we'll have our x squared term and 6x on the left, and
our y squared term and negative 2y, also on the left. I'm moving my constant
term to the right. And I'm regrouping the x terms together, and the y terms
together. We'll add 9 to our x terms, and we'll add that to both sides of our
equation. We add 9 since b over 2 squared equals 9. B is 6. We divide it by 2
which equals 3 and we square it to get 9. To complete the square for the y
terms. We'll add 1 to both sides of the equation. The b here is negative 2. So
negative 2 divided by 2 equals negative 1. And then we'll square it, which
equals positive 1. So these terms terms can be written as the perfect square of
x plus 3 squared. And these three terms could be written as the perfect square
of y minus 1 squared. And then on the right hand side, we simply add these
constants together to get a total of 4. Now our equation is in a form we
recognize. We have h, which is negative 3. And we have k, which is positive 1.
And then our radius is simply the square root of this number, it's 2.